I was a Band Geek through and through I
never really learned to read bass guitar
music too well but I did play bass
guitar we ended up playing at a school
talent assembly we were just this loud
punk rock band and even though most
people didn't like us the energy was so
much that I remember I took my face off
and I just threw it up in the air and
then I got out of the gym and I got
freaked out because I was like oh my
goodness did I break my base but that
was the moment where I was like I need
to make sure I'm in front of people and
Performing because I just love that
feeling I'm Daryl Ducharme and this is
my journey to becoming a Google
developer advocate
[Music]
during college I studied audio
production after school I went to work
for a guitar shop that kind of did all
the different things that you might want
as a musician and I actually worked for
Guitar Center for
almost five years at various stores and
it's because of Guitar Center that I met
some people who introduced me to
wrestling and made me a wrestling fan my
operations manager his brother-in-law
was actually an independent professional
wrestler and he took me to see a show I
was just blown away there was
pyrotechnics and loud music and the
things that they would do in the ring
were just amazing to me I was like where
have you been all my life and I got to
talking with one of the wrestlers and
since I was a store manager I had a nice
clean cut and he said to me
you look like you would make a great
referee I thought about it a long time
and I kept going back to it and my now
wife she said it sounds like you want to
be a wrestler as soon as she said that I
was like yes this is what we're doing
and I went forward I found a gym learned
about getting in shape and then went to
the school and I became a professional
wrestler my wrestling name was Deacon he
was a televangelist because I want him
to be a bad guy and it seems like
televangelists are always telling you
you're a terrible person and asking for
your money two things that people hate
so I built a website for my wrestling
gimmick so my fans could know where I
was going to be I did learn a lot about
programming and Flash and I started to
put that stuff on my website and so I
was like if I'm gonna be on the road I
need something I can do on the road I'll
build websites with the skills that I
have and one of my training clients ran
a business
that did interactive website design and
so I asked him to be my mentor and he
was like sure I'll Mentor you and he
helped me get a couple clients and then
when I decided to retire from wrestling
he's like why don't you come work for me
and that was really my entry into being
a professional developer becoming a
Google developer Advocate was really
intentional because when I learned about
the concept of a developer Advocate sort
of role it seemed like the perfect mix
of my love of performance and my love of
tech the skills that I learned as a
wrestler that have helped me be a better
developer Advocate are the skills of
dealing with an audience and connecting
with an audience because I feel that
that's a skill that a lot of people
don't have one of the things about a
non-traditional background is you bring
a point of you that's very much needed
in lots of lots of projects out there
foreign
[Music]